awesome fight card let's go to another
awesome fight card you were at the Logan
Paul fight yes so that was awesome yes
yeah
no yeah I mean the KSI Tommy Fury fight
sucked man it was just so bad Tommy Fury
is really not good yeah he's like really
bad he's really bad at boxing and like
well compared to what I at this point we
don't know but like professional boxer
yeah compared to what he should be which
is a professional boxer when your
brother's he comes from a legacy of like
boxing like he's just been around it his
entire life he should absorb it like and
listen here's the thing KSI has like
this really weird style which actually
makes sense for how little he's been
boxing he has power and he has speed so
you curate a style that works for what
you have he's not going to outbox a guy
who's been boxing for 15 years by
standing in front of him you have to
curate a style that maximizes the things
that you do well so he was doing this
like karate kind of stance and really
creating distance then lunging in
could do absolutely nothing to mitigate
it yeah like there was no adjustment
made like what do you think the
adjustment is you beat him to the punch
with a straight right okay or you get
the jab going he kind of stuck the jab a
little bit and then kind of stopped but
no change happened like I think Tommy
probably won the fight it was close but
it shouldn't be close yeah ksi's got 15
other [__] jobs and I don't know why
Tommy was like staying with the grab
because that only helps KSI like push
him off you in box was just like no it
was bad it that was a shitty fight to
watch and the other one
was actually that was the only fight of
the night really the other one wasn't
really you can't even call that bro I
the the Logan fight went exactly how we
thought yeah it a decision Logan and
then obviously I didn't think that Dylan
was gonna outbox him I thought Dylan
would box yeah I actually thought Dylan
would win because he sat so confidently
in the seat and was like I'm [__]
going I thought he was going to do a
little bit more of what he did I at
least I called it I knew he was going to
do some UFC [__] stop cuz I know he's
like hey I don't want to take an L so
I'll be like n no sto because I started
fighting
or that's what I figured but I didn't
think he would not throw punches for
five and a half rounds or whatever and
then just try to and he even get the
takedown which is also sad to watch yeah
that was sad I mean you got to give
Logan credit for him not wanting to
engage as much like Logan boxed well
Logan did box well he was Landing
punches and Dylan kept pressuring him
the entire fight like it's not like
Dylan just sat in the corner it was
running Dylan kept pressing but he
couldn't get off he couldn't get off
Logan's coach he got to thank him
because he was just throwing crazy
punches in the beginning if he would
have stayed doing that he would have
tired out he would have made a mistake
and that's Logan's coach said chill yeah
Logan's coach is like yo chill pick your
spot and that's he made that adjustment
and it was a w because Dylan was just
hoping that he just got tired out yeah
and then he was going to land some bck
yeah yeah Dylan wore those punches
though he took big shots and walked them
down like that was impressive to me I
kind of expected that he wouldn't get
knocked out but like the level of shots
he took even body shots and just like
kept on walking just kept coming forward
yeah I just thought he would throw I
don't know three punches yeah yeah no
you want him to be more active and throw
more but you got to give Logan credit
for that it's listen if punches aren't
landing on you it's very easy to throw
punches but when they are landing on you
you're worried about that defense you're
worried about getting caught and he got
caught in a second I thought Logan was
going to drop him in a second this
[__] ain't go down you got to
think Dylan's calculation though is
don't get knocked out if you don't get
knocked out it's his win is not getting
knocked out yeah yeah I guess I I didn't
think he didn't fight I thought he yeah
if he I thought if he lost like a
warrior just based on the way he
presented the fight all right cool man
you went out you got hit you did your
[__] thing to just see and I don't
know much but I just saw this weird
defensive stance didn't throw any
punches and that's where I was like dude
what what is this this is wasting my
life I'm 39 I don't know how long I'm
going to live this is life that I could
be living doing anything El watching a
blank screen I'm feel meditative he owes
you 18 minutes you owe me 18 minutes do
but the Logan the Logan danis fight was
interesting and entertaining the crowd
was into it yeah to you no not to
everybody there like the energy was the
energy was insane to everybody there cuz
there was act action you have to
understand like even if Dylan's just
getting pounded by Logan that's still
what people are there to see they're
there to see a fight the KSI Tommy fight
was hugging the whole time maybe a punch
that was like Beyond boring interesting
you say that it's probably just it's
different being in the room because
watching that on TV it's like the Logan
danis fight was boring as [__] really at
least with the KSI sh it's like all
right he's trying he's not good but he's
trying completely opposite in in the
arena snoozefest for the second one
people starting to look at their phones
like do other things like like booing
like and again this is their home
Hometown and it was just like what the
[__] is going on here but Dylan Logan
was like big shots are getting landed oh
wow big I see I felt bored watching both
yeah and but the second one was a bit
more fun to watch it was more fun but
again the hug it was more frustrating
than boring because it was like anytime
there was action hug hug hug hug and
that was I guess frustrating and not
boring the Logan Dylan fight I found
myself bored again maybe I just expected
Dylan to throw and I don't know boxing
so maybe I was an idiot who bought a
whatever got sold a bill of goods by
Dylan but like I thought Dylan was going
to
throw so interesting like how it's so
like how the narrative changed like the
narrative was he won't even show up yeah
and that changed for you to well why
isn't he just going in there and beating
the [__] out of I mean because that's
what he said right he also said he was
going to show up to the other fights and
then didn't show up so so there was a n
like even before he even came out I was
sitting there and Mike was next to me
was like do you think think he's going
to walk out wow so there was a moment
even before the fight started was is
this fight going to happen I got pretty
convinced it was going to happen but
you're still thinking about a little bit
and the narrative is so shifted to now
it's like yo why didn't he go there and
beat the [__] out him yeah yeah the
energy inside the room though a little
bit to me felt like uh like high school
after school fight energy that makes
perect and that's what all these all
these YouTube fights are going to be
about that because they're not watching
for the skill it feels like a little
weirder though I didn't enjoy the energy
as you go a real boing match a UFC fight
and it's like a bunch of fight fans that
are ready to see like two Warriors
really like high I can see how you get
put off by that after enough like you're
in it long enough and you're like you
know what I don't really like because
like a lot of people trying to be seen
like a lot of people like there's fights
breaking out which is common in fight
sports but like just just felt like
people everyone had
cameras six interviews for everybody's
trying to get a clip everybody's trying
to get a clip of something and
videotaping you and clip it clip it clip
it every person coming up to you and mic
is trying to like get you in some sort
of weird situation where they have this
viral video that's from it it's yeah
that I agree and that was an
uncomfortable energy to be around cuz I
never feel that in a fight like when I
was at the UFC it's not like every
single person there was some form of
influencer that was going to potentially
use me in a compromising situation to
get views yeah and feeling that every
person that ask I'm not someone who says
no to pictures I'm not some somebody
says no to video I always say every
single time but every time I went into
it I was like who is this person and how
are going to try to exploit me did
anybody get you no like I was I I was
pretty I was pretty sharp on it he was
locked in he locked in like you you see
him on stage it's the same Vibe like
well people were like coming up to him
he's like all right okay this person
what like he's like triangulating like I
don't I don't even know if you drank at
all like you were like no I was pretty
yeah I was pretty sharp and I said the
same thing in every single interview
every single interview I I this is the
the Charlamagne tactic that I learned
from the red carpet I was just going to
say that but I like when I was on the
red carpet with him and MTV days he said
genius he would have his stick ready for
whatever they were going to ask him out
cuz they're going to ask the same
question every single time so he had his
bit ready to go and it kind of kills
their clip like if they're just using
you for a clip it's like there's me
saying the same thing the oppos it gives
them a better clip here's your funny
thing okay here's your funny thing that
you could clip but now it's on my terms
not your terms and your terms always
going to be the most lowf so it's just
what is this funny little anecdote that
you could give them so I just had my
thing ready to go and I was just like
whatever they're coming ask y after
seeing those fights is there any
interest left
for influencer figh yes 100 KSI Jake you
could watch this is the thing that
people you want to see KSI it's not
about that can I Counterpoint did you
care at all to see Dylan and Jake or
Dylan and Logan before they started
doing promo these guys are also
entertainers by trade they're great at
promoting their fights so every fight
pretty much when it was announced for
the most part I've been like n and then
by the end I'm like all right I I want
to see how this goes I just so maybe
Jake is probably the only one because we
actually see him getting better but the
others aren't necessarily getting better
it's an it's like yeah but look at your
metric for interest your metric for
interest is skill you're like they're
getting better at the skill and I want
to see skill yeah it's a high school
after school fight okay which I'm
interested in every single time yeah
right if I see two people on the subway
arguing with each other and I think it's
going to
and is your and the more you're invested
in one of those sides the more you're
going to see it so it's not about the
skill it's about these two people that
you really care about you either really
love or really hate and you want to see
Justice right and uh if I switched my
Outlook then maybe I can you like
fighting before this a lot of these kids
that are watching I think weren't fight
fans no like I think they grew up in
YouTube spaces watching young I was I
was sort of it's not surprising but you
go there 14y olds 15y old
oh Goa yeah and so it's like they grew
up watching soccer like being a fight
fan doesn't happen unless you're like a
legacy fight fit like my dad got me into
fighting early you don't get into
fighting until a little bit later maybe
as an adult you start to box for
exercise and you're like oh this is kind
of fun you start watching some boxing
matches Etc or you have like a friend
who's really into it I think because we
had Mike Tyson so it's like we had the I
mean this golden age of [__] boxing
that we came up in and even then it's
not even the biggest sport to me it felt
like if was a Mike Tyson fight everybody
stopped what the [__] they were doing
that night and had the TV on or or if
they had what you could call YouTube
culture surrounding which is like those
247 so HBO did those 247 series and all
of a sudden exactly you're like now I'm
invested in this person that's what
these streamers are doing all the time
that's what these YouTubers doing all
they're getting you invested so if
you're going to see the person that you
love go into a situation where they
could get knocked out MH I got to watch
so I don't think it affects it at all I
mean the [__] was sold the [__] out it
was crazy mhm like oh they made some
money yeah and they were there early
like it wasn't they just like with
regular boxing people show up for the
last fight that [__] was packed when we
showed up word packed wow yeah so I
think it's just about making sure
there's a reason to see people fight
like if Jake wanted to fight Logan right
now you don't think that that would be
crazy that's that one we need to see I
mean like that's the one we need to see
but I don't think we're ever going to
see that I I think I think I think we
could see that I don't think we see that
I think we will see I think we can see
that I don't think we see I think we
will see that do we want to see
that don't want
that just
Sayan don't want no problems I think at
the end of the day these guys are
entertainers and they and they know what
will make money and what will sell they
sell very well and nothing will sell
better no fight maybe in history will
sell better than that I'm not saying it
would be the best fight or even
necessarily a good fight no fight will
have as high of stakes as that ever I'm
fighting my brother I mean who the [__]
is not
interested Logan ain't gonna do that bro
you so after that fight he's like Rey
Mysterio I got
you that's what he want he want a 5 foot
Mexican anybody else still a little high
no come on a do you think you think
Dylan goes UFC um you see him he he
pulled out of Bellator I think release
Bellator I mean that's the most logical
move for him but like he needs to get
training and he needs to like he needs
to train the hands too yeah the
Jiu-Jitsu is nice he's going to be in
the UFC and he's going to be better than
everybody in the UFC at Jiu-Jitsu you
had that but we've seen people who are
nice at Jiu-Jitsu when they go up
against guys that can mitigate the
Jiu-Jitsu and have hands they have real
[__] problems so he needs to get in
there take it serious and do it now if
you're the UFC you go this guy can sell
the [__] out of a fight I mean he just
sold a million pay-per-view and people
were not tuning in for ksit Tommy no
they're tuning in for Logan and Dylan so
he can sell fights so if it's not UFC
maybe it's another one of these
fledgling promotional companies that
wants to get after it and they could put
give the bag to a guy who could sell the
[__] out of a fight so let's see if he
wants to do it also you signed up at
price.com and use the promo code Schultz
they will match your initial deposit up
to $100